en tout cas que je craignais au début de
la COP merci beaucoup Mélanie Vogel pour
votre première réaction aujourd'hui dans
notre émission merci merci beaucoup
Alexandre pour cette première interview
il y aura d'ailleurs une question tout à
l'heure consacrée à la COP 28 mais c'est
surtout la situation politique actuelle
l'avenir du projet de loi immigration
qui vont être au cœur de cette séance
Quentin oui bonjour th bonjour à tous
effectivement alors que on voit sur
cette image géralde Darmanin qui est ici
en train de s'installer au ban des
ministres avec Éric Dupont morettil va
être au cœur de plusieurs questions hein
puisque effectivement il y a cette
séance qui s'annonce mouvementée avec
pas moins de trois présidentes et
présidents de groupe à l'offensive sur
la question du projet de loi immigration
ou sur la crise que traverse nos
institutions ces trois questions
d'actualité et qui vont ouvrir dans
quelques instants la séance à 15h et
avec notamment les socialistes qui
entendent pointer l'échec je cite du
ministre de l'intérieur de la première
ministre et du président de la
République je veux continuer avec ce que
disent le PS cette année de perdu est
une année de perdu pour traiter les
priorités des Français voilà l'angle
d'attaque de Patrick canner qui est l'un
des trois présidents de groupe qui va
interroger le Gouvernement sur ce qui se
passe autour de ce projet de loi
immigration c'est donc ce qui va occuper
les trois premières questions il va
également y avoir un autre sujet majeur
qui va être évoqué celui de la laïcité
le chef de l'État a participé jeudi soir
à une cérémonie religieuse une bévue qui
peut alimenter le communautarisme que
l'on prétend combattre par ailleurs a
dit un sénateur LR qui va poser une des
deux question voilà Tam pour cette
séance qui va être présidée par Gérard
arché qui s'ouvre d'un instant à l'autre
merci merci beaucoup Quentin pour toutes
ces explication effectivement Gérard
lcher s'est installé au plateau et vous
l'avez dit il va y avoir trois questions
de trois présidents de groupe qui vont
ouvrir cette séance de questions Patrick
canner Cécile kckierman et Marie scarer
qui va être la première a posé une
question sur ce qu'elle qualifie de
crise des institutions qui s passé sur
le projet de loi immigration lundi
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le
procèsverbal est donc adopté sous les
réserve
d'usage chers
collègues
madame la première ministreames et
Messieurs les ministre le plaisir de
saluer dans la tribune d'honneur une
délégation de 5 sénateurs conduite par
Pierre Ngolo président du Sénat de la
République du Congo ils sont accompagnés
par nos collègues Guillaume chevrolier
président de groupe d'amitié France
Afrique centrale et Stéphane deil
président délégué pour le Congo au sein
de ce groupe et par son Excellence
Monsieur rodolp Adada ambassadeur de la
République du Congo en France nous
venons d'avoir un entretien
particulièrement dense avec le président
de goollo et sa délégation sur nos
relations bilatérales mais aussi sur les
récentes évolution en Afrique nous avons
signé un protocole de coopération
parlementaire qui contribuera à enrichir
les liens entre nos assemblées dans les
prochaines années en particulier sur le
volet de la décentralisation et des
relations de l'État avec les
collectivités locales qui intéressent
particulièrement nos partenaires
congolais le Sénat français entretient
de longues dates d'excellentes relations
avec le Sénat de la République du Congo
ses rapports de confiance et d'amitié
sont à l'image du partenariat étroit qui
unit nos deux pays permettez-moi mes
chers collègues de souhaiter en votre
nom à tous à nos homologues du Sénat
congolais la plus cordiale bienvenue
ainsi qu'un excellent et fructueux
[Applaudissements]
séjour madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues notre ordre du jour
appelle les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
et sur notre site chacun sera attentif
au cours de nos échanges au respect des
uns et des autres et au respect du temps
de parole je vais donner la parole
immédiatement à madame la Présidente
Marie SCER pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Madame la première
prre ministre à qui profite le crime la
coalition d'opposition que tout oppose à
recaler le projet de loi immigration
quel que soit nos convictions doit-on se
réjouir de la multiplication de ces
blocages institutionnels le 493
répétition une motion de rejet
sommes-nous face à une crise politique
simplement conjoncturelle en partie nous
assistons sans doute aux limites du en
même temps promu par l'exécutif car nous
voyons nous voyons bien que certains
groupes parlementaires rejettent la
culture du compromis et préfère les
coups politiques au débat mais au fond
le RDSE souhaite que l'on s'interroge
davantage sur nos institutions qui
globalement semblent marquer le pas et
traverser une crise assez profonde au
point qu'ici au Sénat nous avons presque
l'impression de vivre un système
monocaméral à défaut de se construire au
Palais Bourbon le dialogue se tente au
Palais du Luxembourg bien entendu en
tant que sénateur on peut se réjouir
d'un Sénat mise en en lumière comme
chambre de modération pourvu toutefois
que le compromis y trouve aussi sa place
avec ouverture et sincérité sur des
sujets fondamentaux pour nos concitoyens
la CMP sur le projet de loi immigration
pourrait avoir ainsi valeur de test
cependant profondément attaché au
bicamérisme et à la démocratie
représentative socle de notre République
le groupe RDSE souhaite voir au plus
vite émerger une gouvernance plus
apaisée dans cette perspective madame la
Première ministre envisagez-vous des
réflexions sur le fonctionnement des
institutions y compris sur la
décentralisation tout cela dans
l'intérêt des Français
merci pour vous répondre à la parole est
à madame la Première ministre vous avez
la parole madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la Présidente Marie
scarer lundi à l'Assemblée nationale la
nupè et l'extrême droite se sont alliés
pour empêcher le débat sur le projet de
loi
immigration comme j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire cette alliance
cette alliance baroque est irresponsable
elle s'est faite au mépris du travail
parlementaire au mépris des attentes des
Français madame la Présidente Marie
scarer je connais l'attitude
constructive de votre groupe tout au
long de la discussion du texte au Sénat
le groupe RDSE est le plus ancien groupe
parlementaire de notre République je
sais son attachement au débat et au
pluralisme je sais également votre
volonté de trouver des solutions
concrètes et efficace pour les Français
notamment face au défis migratoires
cette volonté c'est aussi la mienne
c'est aussi celle du ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald d'Anin et de tout mon
gouvernement nos concitoyens attendent
des solutions et des réponses nos forces
de l'ordre nous demandent des moyens
d'action plus efficaces nous devons
éloigner plus facilement les personnes
en situation irrégulière et mieux
intégrer celle que nous accueillons
c'est l'objectif que poursuit mon
gouvernement c'est je n'en doute pas
l'état d'esprit qui guidera les travaux
de la commission mixte paritaire qui se
tiendra lundi c'est la condition pour
qu'un texte puisse être adopté au Sénat
comme à l'Assemblée nationale la
condition pour apporter des les réponses
attendues par nos concitoyens je vous
remercie madame la
Présidente le président Patrick canner
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain monsieur le Président Madame
la première ministre c'est un
fiasco depuis 2022 le président de la
République subit une crise
institutionnelle vous venez d'y ajouter
une crise politique majeure et inédite
en jouant sur les peurs le président de
la République attise les braises d'un
pays déjà incandescent
oui c'est
irresponsable votre Ministre aux
déclaration à géométrie variable a pris
sur lui l'entière charge du projet de
loi immigration il a
échoué au travers de son échec vous avez
échoué et au travers de votre échec
c'est le président de la République qui
a échoué à vouloir tromper tout le monde
vous n'avez convaincu personne vous avez
provoqué cette situation c'est à vous de
nous en sortir désormais mais puisque
vous écartez un nouvel article 49 alinéa
3 quelle sera l'ampleur de la
capitulation de la majorité
présidentielle en commission mixte
paritaire quel sera le prix du
renoncement aux valeurs républicaine la
suppression de l'aide médicale d'État la
fin de la régularisation des
travailleurs dans les métiers en tension
l'instauration d'une préférence
nationale madame la Première ministre il
est encore
suivez l'exemple du président rotot
retirez votre projet de
loi madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le Président Patrick
canner lundi à l'Assemblée nationale vos
collègues députés socialistes ont pris
une décision lourde ils ont choisi de
mêler leur voix à celle de l'extrême
droite pour empêcher la poursuite des
débats pour empêcher la poursuite des
débats au
Parlement ils ont choisi de refuser
d'exercer leur mission de parlementaire
discuter et voter la loi je me souviens
d'un temps où le parti socialiste
portait des combats et des valeur d'un
temps où il défendait avec force le
Parlement le Parti socialiste était un
parti de gouvernement à l'Assemblée de
plus en plus il s'enferme dans
l'obstruction monsieur le Président
canner je connais la sincérité de vos
convictions je connais votre attachement
à la démocratie parlementaire alors je
vous le demande avec vos collègues
sénateurs socialistes allez-vous laisser
le Parti socialiste se dissoudre au sein
de
l'anupess
allez-vous pouz-vous le laisser sans
rien dire devenir un satellite de la
France insoumise et voter avec le
rassemblement national où comptez-vous
sauver l'honneur du Parti socialiste
défendre ce qui fait son histoire et ses
valeurs en attendant avec mon
gouvernement nous ne laisserons jamais
les manœuvres politiciennes l'emporter
les Français attendent des solutions ils
demandent des mesures fortes face à
l'immigration illégale il souhaite que
nous travaillons pour une meilleure
intégration de que nous accueillons avec
le ministre de l'intérieur c'est ce que
nous sommes déterminés à faire une
commission mixte paritaire se tiendra
lundi nous sommes résolus à apporter des
réponses à nos concitoyens avec mon
gouvernement nous choisirons toujours la
voix de la responsabilité et le chemin
de l'action je vous
remercie monsieur le Président
[Applaudissements]
canner madame la prier ministre je vous
ai posé une question de fond vous poser
de manière politicienne
le vous connaissez vous connaissez la
locution latine bien connu des juristes
nul ne peut se prévaloir de sa propre
turpitude excusez-moi de vous rappeler
que le 14 novembre ici les sénateurs de
votre groupe majoritaire à quelques
exceptions ont voté le texte de la
droite sénatoriale avec toutes les
suppressions que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure alors
je n'ai pas de leçon à recevoir au nom
de mon groupe ne laissez pas vos députés
Renaissance se dissoudre parmi les
députés LR qui se dissou qui se
dissolvent eux-mêmes dans les groupes de
la République de la du rassemblement
national voilà la réalité voilà la
réalité qui est posée madame la Premier
ministre retirez votre
texte la parole est à madame la
Présidente
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologiste
kaki monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre mes chers collègues le
rejet préalable de votre projet de loi
sur l'immigration lundi à l'Assemblée
nationale est un échec cuisant vous osez
dénoncer l'empêchement du débat alors
que vous avez vous-même coupé cours à
toute discussion des députés à 20
reprises tant sur les retraites que sur
les budgets par les 493 successifs vous
allez aujourd'hui nous opposer quand
l'absence d'un tel débat à l'Assemblée
c'est un texte plus dur celui du Sénat
qui devient la base de travail commune
aux deux chambres mais la confusion
madame la Première ministre c'est vous
qui l'avez entretenu en accompagnant ici
le texte de la droite sénatoriale vos
soutiens ici au Sénat on voter le texte
sénatorial alors que votre groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale l'a profondément
travaill
cette incohérence vous l' payz votre
réponse à cet échec et à cette grande
confusion c'est la convocation dans
l'urgence d'une commission mixte
paritaire pour tenter de petits
arrangements nous n'acceptons pas ce
coup de force contre la démocratie cette
mise en cause profonde du Parlement
madame la Première ministre allez-vous
renoncer à la convocation de la
commission mix
paritaire pour vous répondre la parole
est à madame la Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente Cécile
cuckerman à l'Assemblée nationale
lundi ceux qui
prétendent ceux qui prétendent donner
des leçons de démocratie au gouvernement
ont choisi d'empêcher le débat
parlementaire je réponds à la même
question monsieur le sénateur
ce choix mené de concert avec l'extrême
droite n'a pas entamé notre volonté
d'apporter des réponses aux attentes de
nos concitoyens madame la Présidente
Cécile cuckerman les Français
soutiennent notre texte il demandent que
nous puissions expulser plus facilement
les étrangers délinquants ou ceux qui ne
respectent pas les principes
républicains il demande que nous
puissions donner plus de capacité
d'action à nos forces de l'ordre pour
lutter contre l'immigration irrég
régulière il demande que nous
renforcions les sanctions contre les
passeurs contre les marchands de sommeil
il demande que nous intégrions mieux
ceux que nous choisissons d'accueillir
ces objectifs sont ceux de notre texte
nous voulons apporter à nos concitoyens
les solutions qu'ils attendent rien ne
nous fera dévier de cette ligne une
commission mixte paritaire a été
convoquée le débat parlementaire
continue nous souhaitons parvenir à un
accord avec le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald haranin avec mon gouvernement
notre détermination est totale je vous
remercie madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président Madame la première ministre
mes chers collègues C même français que
vous appelez aujourd'hui à la rescousse
étaiit près de 70 % à rejeter le texte
sur les retraites et vous ne les avez
pas écouté les Français ce n'est pas en
même temps comme ça vous arrange les
Français ce sont aujourd'hui les
citoyens de notre pays qui nous
permettent de dire que nous sommes en
République aujourd'hui vous faites le
choix de piétiner le débat parlementaire
en convoquant une commission mixte
paritaire alors même qu'aucun texte n'a
été voté à l'Assemblée nationale et
madame la Première ministre ayons un
discours de sincérité à l'Assemblée
nationale lundi il y a eu des groupes de
gauche il y a eu plusieurs groupes à
droite je vous rappelle madame la
Première ministre que les cinq voix qui
vous ment ne sont pas que le seul fait
de la gauche mais de l'arc républicain
présent ici au Sénat et c'est ce que
vous devez travailler pour répondre à
l'urgence du bien vivre des Françaises
et des Français dans notre pays
merci la parole est à notre
collègue Pascal Martin pour le groupe de
l'Union
centriste monsieur le Président Madame
la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des outres mes hier l'une de nos
collègues députés vous a interrogé sur
la publication imminente d'un décret
très attendu par les 200000 saport
pompiers volontaires en cette période de
Sainte-Barbe ce décret met en œuvre
l'article 24 de la loi du 14 avril
dernier de financement rectificative de
la sécurité sociale pour 2023 article
qui accorde au titre de la solidarité
nationale le droit des trimestres de
retraite supplémentair aux assurés ayant
accompli au moins 10 années d'engagement
continue ou non en qualité de sapport
pompier volontaire or dans sa rédaction
actuelle le projet de décret
d'application de cette disposition
législative en limiterait le bénéfice au
seul sapport pompiers volontaire ayant
eu une carrière hachée c'est-à-dire ne
bénéficiant pas de l'ensemble des
trimestres de cotisation retraite sur
leur carrière ce qui serait en totale
contradiction avec l'esprit du
législateur et viderait le dispositif de
son contenu puisque'alors seul 10 % des
bénéficiaires potentiels seraiit
concerné monsieur le ministre la réponse
que vous avez faite hier à notre
collègue député ne nous a pas
complètement rassuré certes vous avez
affirmé que le décret appliquerait la
loi strictement vous nous et nous vous
en remercions mais en même temps vous
n'avez pas nié que le texte en
préparation restreindrait
considérablement le dispositif dans ces
conditions monsieur le ministre je vous
le demande très solennellement vous
engagez-vous aujourd'hui à ne pas
limiter l'avantage retraite accordé par
la loi du 14 avril dernier au seul
sapport volontaire ne bénéficiant pas de
l'ensemble des trimestres de cotisation
retraite sur leur carrière je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur Gérald
norenin merci monsieur le Président
mdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le le sénateur vous avez
parfaitement raison un décret est
aujourd'hui en discussion au Conseil
d'État il vise à appliquer les très
nombreuses mesures en tout cas il
termine les très nombreuses mesures que
nous avons pris collectivement d'abord
dans la loi matras je voudrais rappeler
qu'évidemment c'est à l'initiative de la
majorité de l'Assemblée nationale et
grâce au députés matras que ces
dispositions extrêmement importantes
pour les sapurs pompiers volontaires é
été tenu et vous les avez soutenu puis
dans des articles du PLFSS et notamment
vous évoquez dans le cadre de la réforme
des retraites pour la première fois des
trimestres supplémentaires pour
reconnaître l'engagement de nos sapeurs
pompiers volontaires le ministre en
charge des Sapur pompiers que je suis
même si c'est partagé évidemment avec
les is que vous connaissez bien est très
favorable non seulement à la loi telle
qu'elle a été votée mais à l'esprit de
la loi tel que vous l'avez présenté et
oui je veux redire devant votre
assemblée que malgré le fait qu'il y a
cette discussion au Conseil d'État ce
décret n'est toujours pas à publi et la
Direction de la Sécurité sociale qui est
sous l'autorité du ministre des comptes
publiques et de la Ministre en charge et
solidarité il y a une discussion et je
veux vous redire que l'arbitrage de la
première ministre est en des fait que
nous respecterons bien sûr et bien
évidemment l'intégralité de la loi et
l'esprit de la loi qui a été voté par
vous-même le président de la Fédération
nationale des SAP pompiers monsieur
Boland euh m'a saisi je lui ai répondu
et je crois que il a été rassuré lui
pardon de pas l'avoir fait pour vous
j'espère compléter ainsi ma réponse à la
suite de la question posée hier par une
député à l'Assemblée nationale nous
aurons à la sortie du texte au Conseil
d'État des discussions évidemment avec
la Fédération nationale des
saportprpiers je m'y engage avec mes
collègues du gouvernement sous
l'autorité de la première ministre mais
je veux vous redire ici que les
trimestres supplémentaires pour les
sapurs pompiers volontaire parce qu'ils
donnent du temps ils donnent leur vie et
leur famille évidemment est touché par
leur engagement qui fait honneur à
l'uniforme et à la République sera
respecter le ministre que je suis il
veillera s l'autorité de la première
ministre Monsieur Pascal
Martin monsieur le ministre merci pour
votre réponse la doctrine opérationnelle
française repose sur la complémentarité
entre les sappport pompiers
professionnels les militaires et les
sapport pompiers volontaires ces
derniers connaissent une grave crise de
de vocation il manque aujourd'hui 50000
saort pompiers volontaires en France
cette légitime demande espérée depuis 40
ans par ces femmes et ces hommes qui
porte cet engagement civique remarquable
est attendu par et pour tous les sapport
pompiers volontaires monsieur le
ministre les saort pompiers volontaires
vous l'z compris compte sur vous afin
que ce texte soit publié dans les
meilleurs délais dans l'esprit adopté
ici au Sénat il y a quelques mois merci
beaucoup la parole de
notreègue groupec
TER merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre vous avez essuyé lundi un
échec Cu cuisant cet échec politique est
surtout moral c'est celui d'une
stratégie folle celle d'un gouvernement
qui avait rêvé de mettre ensemble
quelques miettes d'humanité avec les ID
rances les fantasmes morbides les
obsessions xénophobes les imaginaire
raciste de toutes celles et ceux qui ont
fait de la haine des étrangers la valeur
cardinale de leur projet politique et
leur seul et unique fond de commerce
électoral alors depuis lundi vous
pleurnichez et vous accusez la terre
entière une alliance contre nature se
serait formée contre vous vous nous
l'avez déjà dit trois fois on a compris
mais c'est exactement le contraire qui
s'est passé c'est vous qui avez un jour
imaginé dans le confusionnisme total qui
vous caractérise qu'il était possible de
trouver un équilibre entre la haine et
les valeurs de la République entre
l'égalité et les discrimination entre
l'indignité et l'état de droit entre la
raison et le mensonge et bien cet
équilibre n'existe pas il va vous
falloir choisir alors qu'allez-vous
choisir c'estz une alliance avec la
droite extrême et l'extrême droite comme
vous l'avez fait ici au Sénat conduire
toujours plus à coup de communication
indigne de compromission avec celles et
ceux qui abîment chaque jour la
République la France au bord du gouffre
au point de l' jeter ou bien le retour
vers la raison la respon abilité le cap
de la dignité du respect des valeurs
républicaines retier ce texte il n'a
aucun avenir digne préférer l'inconfort
d'un instant au déshonneur de toujours
retirer ce texte et accepter de
construire avec celles et ceux qui pent
encore les valeurs de la République avec
celles et ceux qui regardent le monde
tel qu'il est sans haine sans hypocrisie
et sans cynisme un texte digne rationnel
humaniste à la hauteur de la promesse
républi
un texte qui traite l'immigration pour
ce qu'elle est ni une menace ni un
problème mais un phénomène
humain pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
Darmanin merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice je pense que vous
êtes bien mal placé en leçon de morale
lorsque vous faites une motion de rejet
du groupe des ver voté par le
rassemblement national avec des clin
d'œil tellement grands qu'ils ont été
vus dans toutes les circonscriptions du
PS de France
madame la sénatrice les leçons de morale
pardon de vous le dire elles ne rentrent
pas pour vous dans la hauteur de débat
que nous avons ce qu'a fait la dupes et
votre groupe voilà quelques heures à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est que vous
avez rejeté non pas le texte vous le
saviez très bien mais le débat à
l'Assemblée nationale vous saviez
pertinemment que ce serait le texte du
Sénat et vous avez poussé ce cynisme
politique pour quelques bons articles
dans la presse sans doute a rejeté par
principe le fait que des mineurs par
exemple ne seraient plus jamais dans les
centres de rétention administratif vous
avez réussi à rejeter d'un seul coup
tout ce que la gauche en 60 ans n'a
jamais fait et que fera le président de
la République alors si vous vous
souhaitiez pas si vous ne souhaitiez pas
que l'ensemble des 150 députés de
l'anupes apporte comme nous l'avons je
crois ici montré au Sénat où majorité
opposition et bien sûr gouvernement on
suprend des amendements même si vous
votiez pas le texte du groupe communiste
du groupe socialiste et de votre groupe
parce que vous vouz refuser le débat
simplement parce que vous vouliez avec
Madame Le Pen faire une alliance contre
nature alors oui mais vous pouvez crier
madame c'est la vérité vous vous êtes
alli avec Madame Le Pen et vous vous
êtes levés ensemble ensemble les deux
partis populistes contre les partis de
gouvernement et ça c'est
honteux la parole est au président
Philippe mouill pour le groupe les
républicain
madame la Première ministre monsieur le
Président Madame la premère ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues tout d'abord avant de
commencer ma question je voudrais
rassurer le président canner et lui dire
que notre groupe n'a pas perdu ses
valeurs ses convictions elles sont
intactes et c'est parce qu'elles sont
intactes que nous avons retiré le projet
de loi constitutionnel revenons-en
maintenant à ma question qui ne traite
pas de l'immigration mais de la parole
de l'état de la parole de l'État le 16
juin dernier un séisme du magéti de 5 8
a frappé le sud de mon département les
de Sèvres ainsi que l'onur de la chambre
maritime et le Sud Vendé 3 jours plus
tard le gouvernement était présent par
l'intermédiaire du ministre Christophe
Béchu pour remercier les services de
sécurité rassurer les élus locaux et
surtout annoncer aux habitants qu'une
procédure accélérée pour déclencher
l'aritté de catastrophe naturelle a être
mise en place 6 mois plus tard malgré
trois commissions interministérielles
seul 22 communes sur les 400 concerné
ont bénéficier de cette reconnaissance
pire h communes proches de l'épissotre
dont parfois 25 % des maisons ont été
touchées et bien non' pas de nouvelle
aujourd'hui de la part de l'État la
commission interministérielle statue à
partir d'un rapport établi par le Bureau
central de sismologie français or pour
certaines communes ce bureau central
n'est toujours pas passé concrètement en
ce début d'hiver quelle réponse
pouvons-nous apporter aux élus locaux
vis-à-vis de leurs habitants qui ont
leur maison en g et pour lequel les
assureurs refusent la prise en charge et
d'une façon plus générale cette question
qui est très locale concerne toutes les
situation de catastrophe naturelle en
France les nombreux territoires qui sont
concernés par les inondations je pense
aussi aux zones qui sont impactées par
le RET gros flement des argiles quoi
répondre aux élus locaux pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires monsieur Christophe
Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Philippe
Mouillet vous avez rappelé la visite que
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire au nom du
gouvernement à la fois pour représenter
la première ministre mais pour
représenter également le ministre de
l'Intérieur en allant sur place au côté
des collectivités devant les maisons
fissurées au milieu de des maires
directement touchés et éprouvés j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire que le gouvernement
mettrait tout en œuvre pour procéder à
cette reconnaissance de catastrophe
naturelle en matière de tremblement de
terre d'après les règles existantes il y
a deux critères cumulatifs le premier
c'est qu'un tremblement de terre doit
dépasser 5 sur l'échelle de richterre et
ça a été le cas puisque nous étions
entre 51 et 54 mais la totalité des
communes puisque quand vous vous
éloignez de l'épicentre pour certaines
d'entre elles on était avec des niveaux
de sismologi qui était inférieure ce qui
explique le besoin à la fois de passage
de ce bureau dont vous avez rappelé
distance et d'examen des dossiers au cas
par cas ce qui fait qu'à la minute où
nous parlons nous n'avons effectivement
vos chiffres sont exacts qu'une
trentaine de communes qui bénéficie de
cette reconnaissance au travers de votre
question dans la continuité des
inondations qu'on a connu au pas
decalais dans la continuité de
difficulté qu'on a pu connaître dans la
vubi ou ailleurs on voit bien à quel
point aujourd'hui nous avons atteint une
fin de cycle par rapport à notre système
de fonctionnement sur les catastrophes
naturelles j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur qui a en
responsabilité le le fait de les
prononcer et nous avons pu ensemble
mesurer un certain nombre de choses dont
nous allons vous proposer des
modifications depuis le fait qu'on
demande à un maire de faire lui-même la
demande alors que parfois la catastrophe
naturelle aboutit à ce que la mairie
soit elle-même frappée directement par
un événement jusqu'aux cas dans lesquels
nous devons le reconnaître puisque quand
vous avez des vents à plus de 200 km
outremer c'est une catastrophe naturelle
et quand c'est en Bretagne ça n'en est
pas on voit bien et ce sera l'occasion
dans les prochaines semaines du plan
national d'adaptation au changement
climatique de tirer toutes les leçons de
ce qui a été reconnu et de ce qui n'a
pas été et de réexaminer la situation de
votre territoire merci pour votre
question monsieur mouiller
oui j'entends votre réponse très
technique moi je vous invite à revenir
dans les deux sèves rencontrer les
personnes que vous avez vu et leur
expliquer comment fonctionne j'ai la
prise en charge lorsque vous vivez avec
des maisons fissurées et des ét dans
dans les pièces je pense que ça
correspond pas aujourd'hui aux attentes
il y a le décalage entre le discours du
jour J et la réalité aujourd'hui qui est
une réalité technique
[Applaudissements]
est à notre collègue M kouim Tok pour le
groupe du Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et
indépendant merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Madame
la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur
géraldanin ministre de l'Intérieur et
des outre ma monsieur le ministre je
déplore que la collectivité française de
Wallis et Funa soit toujours inscrite
sur la liste des pays les moins avancés
de l'OCDE
elle ne bénéficie pourtant pas de l'aide
publique au développement notre
éloignement favorise la chaireté
excessive de la vie et l'accumulation
des monopoles provoque tension et crise
sociale comme le raisent le comme le
récent blocage de la seule banque de
lîle la
BWF j'ai entendu le gouvernement
rappeler la responsabilité de la
collectivité en matière sociale en
préconisant la mise en place d'une
fiscalité directe pour financer les
mesures sociales cependant la réalité
est que sur une population de 12000
habitants seul 2300 personnes sont
salariés fonctionnaires d'État compris
le reste de la population survit
péniblement la location chômage n'existe
pas et le seuil de pauvreté est de 522 €
mensuel le contrat social n'aide que les
personnes âgées les handicapéses ou
celles ayant un revenu en dessous du
SMIC qui est de 784 €. aussi depuis le
début de cette année 2023 je propose la
création du RSA à WIS et foutnois j'ai
d'ailleurs présenté un amendement en ce
sens au PLF 2024 qui a été adopté à
l'unanimité par mes collègues sénateurs
que je remercie chaleureusement monsieur
le ministre nous ne sommes pas éligibles
non plus au Pacte des
solidarités qui a pour ambition de
lutter contre la pauvreté pour cette
raison je sollicite la solidarité
nationale pour doter notre contrat
social de 5 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour financer le RSA
comment le gouvernement compte-t-il
répondre à cette demande qui me semble
parfaitement légitime je vous remercie
pour vous répondre à la parole est au
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outr m
monsieur
Dar merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le
Sénateur nous connaissons votre
engagement pour waliss et fetuna ces
deux magnifiques territoires de de la
République et je sais que vous battez
contre la pauvreté dans ce territoire
comme votre collègue député Michel ce
qui a aussi déposé un amendement comme
le vôtre qui va dans le sens des moyens
votés dans le projet de finances du
ministre deéconomie et du ministre des
comptes publiques et notamment celui de
900000 € pour aider le contrat social il
y a un sujet autour du gage et je sais
que grâce au ministre casenu nous allons
pouvoir retirer le gage et pouvoir tenir
déjà dans le PLF en effet votre demande
d'abondement vous souhaitez également
pouvoir accompagner socialement pour les
personnes qui sont handicapées les
personnes âgées ou les personnes pauvres
un un engagement type RSA ou contrat
social peut-être plus large nous vous
disons notre bien sûr notre allant pour
signer ce tel contrat avec vous il faut
d'abord une délibération de l'assemblée
de Wallis et fotuna avec une
participation de 25 % des crédits par le
territoire puisque vous connaissez la
non compétence de l'État dans ce sens
mais je veux vous dire que à la demande
de la première ministre nous allons y
travailler y travailler le plus
rapidement possible puisque
indépendamment des autres demandes
d'abandement budgétaire que nous allons
accompagner je pense évidemment aux
questions que vous avez posé autour des
investissements du territoire pour 1,4
million d'euros j'aurai l'occasion au
début d'année prochaine de me rendre à
nouveau dans le pacifique et sur votre
territoire avec le ministre en charge
des outres mèes pour pouvoir négocier ce
contrat social en lien avec vous-même le
député et l'assemblée de Wallis et
futounin merci la parole est à notre
collègue Pierre Jean Rochette pour le
groupe Les Indépendants République et
territoire vous avez la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les vers de
Saint-Étienne ont fait la fierté de
toute la France dans les années 70
cette couleur verte cette couleur verte
a été choisie car elle était celle des
magasins du groupe Casino fondé par
Geoffroy Guichard en
1898 aujourd'hui le peuple vert
s'inquiète de l'avenir du groupe Casino
l'entreprise est historiquement
ligérienne et son siège social a
toujours été basé à Saint-Étienne la
marque casino était la première marque
distributeur créée en 1901 elle fait
partie du patrimoine français ces
dernières semaines la situation
financière du groupe s'avè
particulièrement préoccupante pour tous
les employés en attendant l'arrivée de
nouveaux actionnaires en janvier la
vente des hypermarchés et supermarché
est en cours de discussion dans mon
département le malaise est palpable d'un
côté les personnels des magasins qui
seraient cédé ainsi que les salariés de
la logistique craignent d'être les
perdants de cette restructuration de
l'autre cette opération risque
d'entraîner la suppression de postes au
siège social stéphanois qui emploie 1800
salariés c'est es sont largement partagé
l'ensemble du groupe ne risque-t-il pas
d'être fragilisé après une session
importante de son parc de magasins et de
ses entrepôt le siège social pourra-t-il
bien être maintenu à Saint-Étienne
est-il indispensable d'envisager un
découpe un découpage d'une telle ampleur
sur les 22000 personnes que l'enseigne
Casino emploie en France 6000 emplois
directs pourrait être menacé c'est
pourquoi j'attire votre attention
monsieur le ministre sur le risque
majeur que sera l'effondrement de ce
groupe historique et emblématique il
serait un coup dur pour notre
département mais aussi pour notre pays
monsieur le ministre pour tous les
Nigériens qui sont dans une démarche
tous les Nigériens sont dans une
démarche bienveillante vis-à-vis du
groupe krétinski qui uvre à la reprise
de casino mais que peut faire le
gouvernement pour l'assister au mieux et
sauver cette entreprise avez-vous des
échanges avec le repreneur sur l'avenir
du siège social à Saint-Étienne et
comment comptez-vous l'accompagner afin
que le maximum d'emploi soit
préservé la parole est au ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
Monsieur le
Maire Monsieur le
[Musique]
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs sénateur Rochet m'a posé une
question sérieuse à laquelle je pourrais
répondre si vous le
permettez les salariés du Groupe Casino
monsieur le sénateur n'ont pas à payer
pour les erreurs stratégiques commis
depuis plusieurs années par la direction
du
groupe le groupe a commis des erreurs
stratégiques il s'est mal positionné il
a eu des prix plus élevés que tous ses
concurrents et évidemment il a été
particulièrement percuté par la crise
inflationniste il accuse donc des pertes
au dernier trimestre pour vous donner un
seul chiffre c'est un demi milliards
d'euros de perte supplémentairire sur un
trimestre c'est absolument intenable je
suis au côté des salariés j'ai reçu ce
matin l'intersyndical pour faire le
point avec elle je continuerai à les
recevoir et je suis là pour défendre les
intérêts des salariés et garantir le
respect de l'ordre public économique
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire d'abord
éviter la cessation de paiement il y a
quelques mois le groupe Casino était au
bord de la cessation de paiement il
fallait trouver des repreneurs mais il
fallait assurer la jonction nous l'avons
fait en prenant à notre charge le
paiement des charges sociales et des
charges fiscales à hauteur de 300
millions d'euros qui ont été mis dans
une fiduci et qui doivent être
remboursés par le repreneur nous avons
en deuxième lieu aidé à trouver un
repreneur il y en a eu je le rappelle
qu'un seul qui a pu mettre sur la table
le milliard d'euros nécessaire pour la
reprise maintenant il faut garantir
l'avenir du groupe et donc s'assurer
qu'avec le reste de la grande
distribution française l'ensemble des
salariés puisse trouver une solution je
suis donc en contact avec
l'intersyndical je suis évidemment en
contact avec le repreneur Daniel
kretinski et en contact avec l'ensemble
des distributeurs qui voudrai reprendre
une partie des activités du Groupe
Casino pour assurer laass survie de
l'activité et la survie des magasins je
seraai attentif une fois encore à trois
points essentiels le premier c'est
évidemment l'emploi garantir que dans
les offres de reprise qui pourraient
être faites par les uns ou par les les
autres pour les hypers et pour les
supermarchés qui sont aujourd'hui des
centres de perte pour le groupe le
maximum d'emplois soit préservé la
deuxième chose c'est sur les centres
logistiques il y a 13 centres
logistiques quand il y a une reprise il
y a un grand risque que le distributeur
a déjà son centre logistique dont ne le
reprennent pas là aussi je seraiis
vigilant sur l'emploi dans les centres
logistiques enfin évidemment première
des préoccupations le siège de
Saint-Étienne il y a 1800 emplois je
rappelle que sur ces 1800 emplois s vous
plat 12 sont consacrés aux hyper au
super nous veillons aussi au maintien du
siège de
Saint-Étienne la parole est à notre
collègue hervenaud pour le groupe les
républicains monsieur le Président chers
collègues ma question s'adresse
également à monsieur le ministre Bruno
LEM sur la situation également de casino
voyez combien cette situation préoccupe
les élus du territoire pré occupe les
habitants et combien cette préoccupation
transcende effectivement l'éclivage
politique il il en il en va également
d'une question de de souveraineté
économique pour notre pays l'histoire de
casino et de Saint-Étienne sont
intimement lié le siège du groupe est
installé depuis 125 ans géofr Guichard
en est tout un symbole actuellement nous
assistons à un crash économique en
direct une stratégie inadaptée a siphoné
les comptes du groupe qui présente une
dette habissale évalué il est vrai à
près de 12 milliards d'euros comment
d'ailleurs un PDG a-t-il pu jongler avec
les finances du groupe tout en étant
dans le même temps l'actionnaire
principal le démantèlement a commencé il
y a maintenant plusieurs mois avec la
vente de marques à l'étranger puis en
France des ventes à la découpe hier
goport dont on connaît la suite Leader
Price demain peut-être Monoprix franc
prix Vival Naturalia ou cdiscoun 300
hyper et supermarchés sont actuellement
sur la Salette l'intersyndicale à juste
titre est très inquiète et craint que
dans la foulée les entrepôts logistiques
ne puissent être maintenus les syndicats
ont alerté contte sur le soutien du
président de la République lui-même
qu'en est-il monsieur le ministre nous
sommes proches d'une ce sociale sans
précédent 50000 emplois en France 4000
rien que dans la Loire sont menacés
monsieur le ministre depuis les propos
que vous avez tenu en juillet dernier
les choses ont visiblement évolué
défavorablement le plan initial n'est
pas respecté vous avez reçu l'Inter
syndical effectivement ce matin
pouvez-vous apporter la garantie du
maintien du siège et des emplois à
Saint-Étienne nos habitants ne veulent
pas revivre le traumatisme d'un nouveau
Manu France
merci pour vous répondre la parole au
ministre de l'Économie des Finances
Monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
Maire et monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur je vous redis que je n'ai
qu'une seule priorité c'est le maintien
de l'emploi et la préservation de
l'emploi et à Saint-Étienne et dans les
hyper et les supermarchés mais je pense
que vous avez décrit parfaitement la
situation il y a eu des erreurs de
positionnement stratégique de la part de
la direction de casino depuis des années
avec un positionnement sur des prix
élevés là où les concurrents faisaient
des prix bas et quand il y a une
inflation sur les produits alimentaires
bien évidemment cette stratégie
économique a mené le groupe droit dans
le mur et les chiffres de pert que vous
avez donné sont les bons 50000 emplois
qui du coup ont été menacé nous avons
garanti la reprise nous avons pris à
notre charge les dettes sociales et les
dettes fiscales et nous accompagnons
maintenant la reprise par d'autres
groupes de distribution je suis
convaincu que les possibilités de
reprise permettront de relancer
l'activité des upers des supers mais
également les centres de profit que sont
les Monoprix les Francs prix les spars
les petits magasins qui sont en
centre-ville maintenant d'utre
préoccupation je le redis c'est le
centre de Saint-Étienne l'engagement que
j'ai pris c'est sur le maintien du siège
mais il y a des réalités économiques et
je ne les ai jamais caché sur les 1800
personnes qui travaillent sur ce siège
12 travaillent dans les hyper et les
supermarchés
200 ont déjà été cédés au groupe
Intermarché d'autres vont être cédés
dans les mois qui viennent pour garantir
la pérenité de l'activité et la
pérennité de l'emploi l'engagement que
j'ai pris et qu'a pris le repreneur
Daniel kretinski c'est le maintien du
siège à Saint-Étienne je veillerai à ce
que cet engagement soit tenu merci la
parole est à notre collègue Alexandre
wiy pour le groupe socialiste écologiste
et
républicain merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Intérieur le 6 décembre à l'Élysée il
a été porté atteinte au principe de
séparation des Églises et de l'État un
ministre du culte en l'espèce le grand
Rabin de France a allumé la première
bougie d'anuka dans la salle des fêtes
du palais présidentiel en présence du
chef de l'État ceci est radicalement
contraire à la Constitution au principes
qui nous fondent fondamentalement au
principe qui nous lit et au fait que le
Président de la République en est le
garant monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur ma question elle est
finalement assez simple dans l'Oise il y
a quelques jours nous avons rendu
hommage à Ferdinand Buisson nous avons
dit que le la religion libre dans l'état
libre c'était la règle qui nous sur
laquelle nous nous
retrouvions comment peut-on imaginer que
le Président de la République réubl
aujourd'hui est commis un tel impère par
rapport aux règles de laïcité comment
peut-on aujourd'hui vous faire confiance
lorsque la Premier ministre depuis
Mayotte nous dit qu'il s'agit là
simplement d'un soutien à la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur on ne combat pas
l'anti on ne combat pas l'antisémitiste
avec des offices religieux pouvez-vous
pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît nous
confirmer que il n'y aura pas de messe
de Noël à Matignon cette année qu'il n'y
aura pas de rupture du jeûne au
printemps au ministère de l'Intérieur
pouvez-vous nous dire que les palais de
la République ne seront pas le lieu
d'office cultuel pouvez-vous tout
simplement nous dire que c'était un
accident et non un précédent je vous
remercie B vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
Darmanin monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs sénateurs monsieur sénateur
si vous trouvez dans l'actualité
française comme très grande difficulté
pour nos concitoyens le fait que le
Président de la République est reçu et
personnellement j'en suis fier le prix
par des rabins du monde entier de la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme au nom de
l'engagement de la France je crains que
nousons pas le même sens de
priorités c'est d'autant plus étonnant
au moment où nos compatriotes juifs et
vous le savez très bien connaisse 1800
actes et actions antisémit depuis le
prier janvier et quelque part monsieur
monsieur le
sénateur votre provocation qui consiste
à évoquer des messes à Matignon
je ne sais quelle
ou je ne sais quelle cérémonie
religieuse dans n'importe
quel dans n'importe quel dans n'importe
quel édifice public montre sans doute
que vous n'z pas pris la hauteur de ce
qu'il faudrait pour nos concitoyens
juifs patriotes juif qui protège que
protège la République vous savez vous
signez monsieur Bisson mais chacun à sa
gauche permettez-moi de citer monsieur
jores à propos de la loi de séparation
des aiguises et de
l'état la loi la loi laisse sa liberté à
tous les cultes la liberté de conscience
sera garantie et complète partout et
absolue la loi telle qu'elle est est
libérale juste et SAG c'est dommage que
le Parti socialiste s'éloigne encore de
jores
quelques
[Applaudissements]
secondes nous sommes éloignés de
personne ce n'est pas parce que ce n'est
pas votre actualité monsieur monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et on le
comprend bien que ce n'est pas une
actualité pour les Français c'est un
principe fondateur de la République et
en ne le respectant pas en n'admettant
pas cette faute vous tombez de marche en
marche tous les
jours merci la parole est à notre
collègue François budom pour le group
les
républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre jeudi dernier à l'invitation du
président de la République une cérémonie
marquant le début de la fête juif de
ranuka s'est déroulé dans la salle des
fêtes de l'Élysée à cette occasion le
président de la République a convié le
grand Rabin de France et de fait il a
participé à cette grande fête religieuse
pourtant la simple prudence et plus
encore le rôle qui est le sien comme
protecteur de la laïité aurait dû le
dissuader de se prêter à une tel
cérémonie au regard de son rôle
éminent de la au regard de la
Constitution qu'au regard du lieu
emblématique dans lequel s'est déroulé
cette cérémonie à caractère religieux
alors Monsieur le
Ministre partagez-vous l'analyse selon
laquelle le président de la République a
commis une erreur au regard de la
fonction qui est la sienne et comment à
l'avenir comptez-vous combattre une t
une telle atteinte à la
laïcité pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de
l'Intérieur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le
sénateur mais vous inquiétez pas chacun
aura son grand
homme monsieur le sénateur bonhomme
monsieur le Président mesames messieurs
les
sénateurs c'est étonnant que le groupe
qui soutenait alors le général Gaulle ne
se posait pas qu'une
chapelle qu'une chapelle exista à
l'Élysée où le général avec sa famille
faisait et c'est bien normal faire son
office en pleine 5e République
pensez-vous monsieur le sénateur que
c'est ça qui touche notre pacte
républicain le fait que l'antisémitisme
soit mis en avant par des questions
d'actualité lorsque nous nous luttons
monsieur le
sénateur lorsque nous luttons
collectivement contre l'atteinte faite à
nos compatriotes Juifs pensez-vous que
ce sont les Juifs de France qui portent
atteinte et le grand Rabin qui ramène
une bougie wiitz puisqu'il s'agit de ça
monsieur le sénateur pensez-vous que
c'est ça la conception que vous avez des
attentes àé citer je pense que c'est
plutôt l'islam radical je pense que
c'est plutôt les attaques des
associations communautaristes pour
lequel le gouvernement a fait voter la
loi séparatisme fait fermer des mosquées
radicales attaque ici ou là des
commerces communautaires ne trouvez pas
des polémiques inutiles il n'y a pas eu
de cérémonie religieuse à l'Élysée il y
a eu un moment où le président de la
République a reçu un prix cont
antisémitisme il serait bon que nous
nous initions contre le vrait
obscurantisme c'est le radicalisme
religieux c'est pas nos compatriotes
[Applaudissements]
Juifs monsieur le ministre quand on
convoque jores ou de Gaul il faut avoir
les citations et l'esprit clair si si de
Gaul a effectivement installé à ses fris
une petite chapelle sur la cour
d'honneur donant sur la cour d'honneur
de l'Élisée c'était uniquement pour
célébrer les messes privées ça fait une
grosse différence enfin Monsieur le
Ministre euh et ça confirme votre
réponse quelque peu tortiller mais je
crois que c'est pas il s'agit pas
simplement d'une maladresse une d'une
bévue une maladresse il s'agit surtout
de de considérer qu'il y a une certaine
confusion mentale qui a eu lieu vendredi
à l'Élysée que la célébration n'avait
pas sa place à l'Élysée et qu'en
méconnaissant le souci de neutralité
religieuse notamment dans le contexte de
tension que nous connaissons vous avez
offert là un prétexte fâcheux pour que
des communautés religieuses s prév et s
engouffre dem même vous donnerz un même
motif parfois inespéré pour certains
pour nourrir un nouvel antisémitisme
auquel nous sommes confrontés en
accréditant l'idée selon laquelle
absurde selon laquelle la communauté
juive aurait été privilégiée autrement
dit c'est une peu la politique du
gribouille pour éviter d'être mouillé
vous êtes jeté à l'eau enfin dernier
élément sur la politique
communicationnelle du gouvernement on a
sorti la journée de la licité on a sorti
le le dépliant de la licité le référent
lacité une une journée de la laïcité et
pourquoi pas un numéro vert alors
Monsieur le Ministre peut-être
communiquerez-vous tous ces objets
publicitaires au président de la
République pour qu'il se
reprenne monsieur le Président ni mess
ni polémique dans ma question mais
simplement le constat depuis plusieurs
semaines de grandes intempéries dans les
territoires de France
dans mon département les Hautes Alpes 47
communes ont demandé le classement en
reconnaissance de catastroph naturelles
suite aux intempéri des 15 derniers
jours plusieurs questions la première
madame la ministre pouvez-vous
m'indiquer où en est la reconnaissance
en catastrophe naturelle pour ces
communes deuxè question vous avez
annoncé lors de votre visite dans mon
département pour accompagner le malheur
de mes concitoyens et des élus locaux le
fait qu'il n'y aurait aucune aucun reste
à charge pour les collectivités impacté
par ces intempéries qu'en est-il 3e
question le ministre Béchu a évoqué à
plusieurs reprises dans cet hémicycle la
perspective d'un décret qui viserait à
faciliter et à simplifier les conditions
de curage et d'entretien de nos réseaux
d'eau de Canau de rivière dans les
territoires de France qu'en est-il c'est
une attente profonde dans nos
territoires merci pour vous répondre la
parole est à la ministre délégué en
charge des collectivités territoriales
madame fort merci Monsieur le présid
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Arnaud
d'abord merci de vous être excusé auprès
de moi de pas pouvoir m'accompagner
lorsque je me suis rendu sur les lieux
auprès de ces trois communes
permettez-moi tout d'abord de dire tout
le soutien du gouvernement aux élus et
effectivement vos collègues étaient
présents et l'ont vu mais aussi des
départements limitrophes j'ai tenu à me
rendre personnellement vous le savez je
salue l'engagement de nos services de
secours des agents de l'État des
collectivités mais aussi des entreprises
qui sont revenus tout simplement mettre
le t
dans son lit dans la rivière soyez
assurés que la solidarité nationale
s'exprimera également pleinement d'abord
vous m'interroger sur les 37 dossiers
oui ces 37 dossiers communaux de demande
de reconnaissance de l'état de
catastrophe naturelle ont déjà constitué
et obtenu un avis favorable de la
commission
interministérielle les autres dossiers
certains pourraient être en retard
Monsieur le Préfet a dit que pendant 48h
72h il accepterait que les dossiers
arrivent et donc on a mis un peu de
souplesse dans ces sollicitations il
convient d'aider financièrement les
communes en mobilisant l'aide de l'État
le soutien des conseils régionaux et
départementaux je salue à la fois le
président de votre département monsieur
le sénateur et le président de votre
région sud qui ont tous deux dit que
bien sûr il seraiit au côté de l'État au
côté des communes sinistré nous sommes
donc pleinement mobilisés avec le
ministre Gérald daranin sur ce sujet et
des points d'étapes réguli sont d'ors et
déjà prévu j'ai les portables évidemment
des maires principalement concernés et
j'ai déjà échangé avec eux par ailleurs
l'entretien des cours d'eau est un
élément important que vous avez cité
c'est votre troisème question dans nos
politique de lutte contre les
inondations afin de simplifier ces
opérations vous l'avez cité Christophe
Béchu a transmis début novembre au
Conseil d'État un projet de décret
facilitant les opérations de curage
ponctuel des cours d'au visant à
restaurer leur fonctionnalité naturelle
ce décret pourra être publié à l'issue
des travaux du Conseil d'État et
vraisemblablement au tout début de
l'année 202 je rappelle le travail de
fond engagé collectivement avec mes
collègues Bruno Le Maire et Christophe
Béchu sur
l'assurabilité des collectivité local
nous avons effectivement mandaté une
mission sur ce sujet ensemble avec les
représentants les élus locaux les
assureurs nous allons nous assurer du
bon accompagnement de toutes les
collectivités qui subissent ces
catastrophes naturelles je vous
remercie oui madame la ministre je vous
remercie de ces précisions de votre
visite et vous avez à juste titre salué
l'engagement des collectivit invités
local des élus mais aussi des
professionnels et également des citoyens
qui ont fait preuve de grande dignité à
l'occasion de ces événements 12 millions
d'euros à la seule charge du département
des Hautes Alpes 15 millions d'euros de
travaux à réaliser vous m'avez indiqué
sans le dire qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'autofinancement à la charge des
collectivités locales j'espère que vous
le confirmerez dans les prochaines
semaines et je vous en remercie je crois
qu'il y a un vrai sujet au-delà de mon
département c'est la gestion gmapi d'un
certain nombre de cours d'eau avec la
nécessité de travailler à mon aval à une
plus grande solidarité entre les
différents acteurs d'une part et d'autre
part faire en sorte que l'on puisse de
manière réglementaire davantage
intervenir et en prévention en
précaution sur ces cours d'eau pour
éviter demain d'avoir davantage encore
de catastrophe il faut sortir du dogme
on n'intervient pas sur un cours d'eau
en amont pour préserver la biodiversité
lorsqu'il y a une catastrophe il n'y a
plus de biodiversité tout part à la mer
ou tout part effectivement avec l'eau de
la montagne il est absolument nécessaire
de faire bouger les lignes en la matière
je vous remercie la parole est un d'utre
collègue Jean-Baptiste blanc pour le
groupe les
[Musique]
républicains monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
donc après
merci après DESP et desfe et zan que
nous connaissons toutes et tous
désormais c'est un nouvel acronyme au
Roland cosmétique qui s'impose en France
les cops régionales que vous installez
chaque semaine dans chaque région en
dehors de tout contrôle parlementaire et
la méthode est toujours la même un haut
fonctionnaire décide seul à Paris et les
collectivité se débrouilleent sans
compétences ni moyens supplémentaires en
lançant une nouvelle étape de
territorialisation écologique le 25
septembre dernier la première ministre
annoncé la méthode le secrétariat
général à la planification écologique
qui ne rend compte à personne élabord
des slides désincarnés transmises aux
régions et cette façon de faire n'est ni
coopérative ni transparente puisque
qu'elles se sont déjà engagées
elles sontjà engagées depuis et depuis
longtemps dans la transition écologique
les régions ne sont pas seul euh à agir
les régions en tout cas n'ont pas les
marges de manœuvre euh qu'on veut bien
leur donner sur les 40 leviers de
décarbonation les 150 actions types les
160 questions oui ou non à la seule
semaine de l'État qu'on leur soumet les
régions sont continte de transcrire les
décisions de l'État dans des stratégies
nationales sous lestroit de surveillance
des des préfets et sans les élus très
souvent malheureusement c'est un
contrôle de conformité étatique qui nous
ramène peut-être a temps de la tutelle
d'avant 1982 la loi vous oblige pourtant
à présenter tous les 5 ans une loi de
programmation énergétique servant de
base à la déclinaison territoriale nous
attendons toujours cette grande loi
monsieur le ministre est simple la
question est simple comment pouvez-vous
être à la fois le ministre qui a accepté
avec nous pendant des mois et des mois
la territorialisation du zan par exemple
et en même temps être celui d'une
planification écologique imposée aux
régions une fois passé le temps de la
communication des copes régionales quels
seront les moyens financiers que vous
envisagerez pour pour les conférer à ces
collectivités pour réussir la transition
écologique pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de la transition
écologique monsieur
béch monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Jean-Baptiste blanc j'ai un
défaut que je dois confesser
ici je ne vous réjouissez pas je je n'en
confesserai
qu'un j'ai passé 6 ans au Sénat et ça
m'a durablement déformé en étant
convaincu que non seulement cette
chambre est précieuse pour la République
mais que d'autre part ce qu'on apprend
et ce qu'on dit ici dans le fait de
travailler avec les élus locaux est une
des manières de faire en sorte de
réussir à réformer ce pays dans la
circulaire du 29 septembre dernier sur
les COP territoriales il est écrit à la
fin du premier paragraphe du haut de la
page 3 que les parlementaires sont
systématiquement invités à l'ensemble de
ces copes territoriales et présentant
votre question j'ai vérifié que vous
aviez vous-même été destinataire de
l'invitation et ça a été le cas à la COP
territoriale de la région sud j'ai ce
matin en Bourgogne installé une de ces
copes et il est dommage que vous n'ayez
pas pu vous rendre à celle qui s'est
tenue un lundi à Marseille parce que
vous auriez pu mesurer que c'est
exactement l'inverse de ce que vous
venez de décrire nous faisons très
exactement l'inverse nous sommes
inflexibles sur une ambition nous avons
pris des engagements climatiques
collectivement y compris avant ce
gouvernement en disant que nous devions
baisser nos émissions et dans ce
contexte pour tenir cette ambition il y
a une méthode c'est la planification et
il y a un choix c'est de faire confiance
au territoire la première étape c'est
celle du diagnostic la photo de ce que
sont les émissions Les leviers qui sont
disponibles c'était le cas ce matin avec
des dizaines de maires de la région
Bourgogne avec 400 participants à Dijon
c'était le cas il y a quelques jours en
Occitanie ce sera le cas dans quelques
jours en auverne ronalp où je ne doute
pas qu'on aura l'occasion de parler zan
à nouveau avec le président vquier dans
les 6 mois qui viennent département par
département et à l'échelle des communes
on va remonter les actions qui sont déjà
mises en œuvre et faire ensuite en sorte
que dans le cadre du fond vert on puisse
faire en sorte que les crte deviennent
des contrats de réussite de la
transition écologique et qui bénéficie
financement parmi lesquels une partie de
ce qui a été voté dans cet hémicycle sur
le soutien au territoires qui mettent en
place des pcaet voilà la méthode voilà
l'explication monsieur
blanc don Tacte monsieur le ministre
pourquoi avons-nous une impression de de
gos plan qui qui dit pas son nom il va
falloir vraiment veiller à cette
gouvernance et éviter cette écologie
PowerPoint à laquelle on assiste
sincèrement et tenir compte des actions
de décarbonation déjà conduites par les
collectivités du bloc communal et des
conseilsart
mon merci la parole est à notre collègue
Denis boî pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
République merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je veux ici dans
notre hémiycle témoigner solennellement
de la détresse d'un grand nombre de
vignerons je suis moi-même trop souvent
exposé à cette souffrance sur mon
territoire le 25 novembre à Arbonne ils
étaient 6000 viticulteurs d'Occitanie à
manifester dans lecal
monsieur le ministre vous le savez seul
un accompagnement massif de l'État
permettra une sortie de crise c'est
pourquoi nous demandons un plan Marchal
pour la viticulture un plan Marchal bien
sûr mais à deux détages en premier lieu
les aides d'urgence doivent servir à
sauver les exploitations confronté à
d'importantes difficultés de trésorerie
elles doivent être justement calibrées
il faut que les fonds soient débloquer
rapidement afin d'être réellement utile
et efficace et qu'aucune aucune
exploitation doit être laissé sur le
côté une handée blanche doit être
également être mise sur la table ensuite
le deuxième étage c'est la construction
d'un plan d'avenir pour la filière
autour de deux grands objectifs d'une
part permettre à toute une génération de
viticulteurs de sortir dignement
dignement de la profession après une vie
de travail d'autre part encourager le
renouvellement des générations en
facilitant l'installation des jeun
agriculteur face aux tensions qui existe
sur le marché il faudra recourir à de la
arrachage de l'arrachage temporaire
certes mais aussi de l'arrachage social
correctement
indamnisé sécuriser les nouvelles
générations c'est également apporter des
réponses au déf climatique avec
l'adaptation des pratiques des cépages
l'accès à la ressource en eau et aussi
l'enjeu de la résilience à travers
l'assurance récolte sur ce point
monsieur le ministre nous attendons
toujours que le gouvernement engage le
discussion pour une sortie de la
référence olympique monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous aujourd'hui rassurer les
hommes et les femmes qui par leur
savoir-faire font la fierté de nos
territoire pouvez-vous leur apporter des
réponses d'abord sur un juste calibrage
des mesures d'urgence ensuite sur un
plan d'avenir pour laffilière
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
au porte-parole du gouvernement monsieur
Veron merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Denis BOAD alors
hélas je ne suis pas le ministre de
l'Agriculture néanmoins néanmoins j'ai
l'honneur
j'ai l'honneur de partager une passion
avec vous monsieur le
sénateur je partage une passion avec
vous monsieur le sénateur la passion
pour le bon vin et la passion pour le
patrimoine culturel et pour le
patrimoine viticole qui en fait partie
je ne mconnais pas Monsieur Nous ne
mconnaissons pas évidemment les
difficultés rencontrées par la
profession des viiculteurs vous l'avez
dit les reprises d'exploitation agricole
faire face au désastres climatiques le
mildou pour prolonger le débat que vous
avez eu la semaine dernière au Sénat
j'avais moi-même pu constater c'était
pas dans le Sud-Ouest mais d'autres spag
on voudrait pas ou des agriculteurs
commencent à arracher des spages
traditionnels français pour planter à la
place des sépages italiens portugais
espagnol plus résistant à la chaleur ce
qui a évidemment aussi un impact
culturel patrimonial très fort dans ce
milieu des viticulteurs qui aiment la
terre qui aiment leur pays et qui aiment
le faire savoir Monsieur le Sénateur
vous posez une question factuelle sur
comment accompagner comment l'État
peut-il accompagner les viticulteurs qui
font face aux grandes difficultés cette
année notamment les viticulteurs du
Sud-Ouest et là si vous le savez savez
ça vous a été répondu par le ministre
Marc fenau il n'y a pas de dispositif
aujourd'hui légal permettant de mettre
en place un fond tel que vous le
souhaitez néanmoins je vous le rappelle
volontiers face à une situation
économique particulièrement dégradée
dans certains bassins de production le
fond d'urgence de 20 million d'euros qui
a été voté dans le cadre du PLF et que
le Sénat a voté il y a peu va être
déployé afin d'accompagner les
viticulteurs les plus en difficulté de
trésorerie et donc notamment dans le
sud-ouest par ailleurs en lien avec la
filière nous comp continuons à
expertiser des soutiens complémentaires
pour accompagner les viticulteurs dans
la crise qu'ils traversent et je veux
rappeler l'engagement fort du
gouvernement en faveur de la viticulture
le gel en 2021 ça a été 572 millions
d'euros de soutien le gel en 2022 ça a
été 17 millions d'euros de soutien la
grê en 2022 ça été 26 millions d'euros
de soutien vous voyez qu'à chaque fois
l'état est capable de se mobiliser pour
soutenir la viticulture cette année
encore 200 millions d'euros pour un
dispositif exceptionnel deiliation et le
ministre de l'Agriculture a par ailleurs
annoncé qu'un travail serait mené pour
la mise en place d'un dispositif de prêt
bonifié je vous remercie merci la parole
est à notre collègue Pascal grunny pour
le groupe les républicains merci
monsieur le Président la France voit ses
petits commerces mourir à petit feu pas
un jour ne pas sans que nous ne soyons
sollicités par des commerçants à bout de
souffle qui ne parviennent plus à se
verser de salairire et qui envisagent de
baisser le riz d'au en quelques années
ils ont eu à subir la crise sanitaire
l'explosion des prix de l'énergie les
taxes comme la CF feu un pouvoir d'achat
des Français en Bern et la concurrence
redoutable du commerce en ligne beaucoup
d'entre eux doivent encore rembourser
péniblement leurs PGE ou leurs échéan
sur SAF et comme si cela ne suffisait
pas vous avez encouragé à la veille de
Noël une publicité de laadem mettant en
scène des dévendeurs pour inciter à la
déconsommation une nouvelle gifle pour
les 700000 commerce de proximité qui
font pourtant vivre plus de 3 millions
de Français et jouent un rôle essentiel
dans dans la vie sociale de nos
territoires alors que les élus locaux ne
cessent de tirer la sonnette d'alarme et
vous ont remis à plusieurs reprises des
propositions concrète vous ne semblez
pas avoir pris conscience de la gravité
de la situation monsieur le ministre les
mesures cosmétiques ne suffisent plus
quelles mesures concrètes entendez-vous
prendre pour soutenir véritablement nos
commerces de proximité écrasés par la
conjoncture je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de la transition
écologique la cohésion des territoires
vous avez parole monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
gruni chaque jour nos concitoyens
nous-même nous sommes soumis à 20000
spots
publicitaires j'avoue je confesse et
j'assume que non pas avant les fêtes de
Noël pendant les 10 jours qui précèdent
le Black Friday 53 spots par jour sur
ces 20000 ont incité à se poser la
question de comment nous achetions et de
ce que nous
achetions en suggérant qu'on se demande
si parfois il fallait pas plutôt réparer
que d'acheter du neuf en suggérant
d'insister sur le reconditionner en
suggérant d'insister sur le recycler en
suggérant d'insister sur la location un
de ces spots avec un dévendeur puisque
c'était le thème de cette campagne de
laadème a suscité une émotion en disant
vous vous trompez de cible pas forcément
de message mais de cible puisqueon cible
un commerce physique et qu'aujourd'hui
le principal problème c'est pas les
commerces physiques ce sont les
plateformes
on est dans le paradoxe que vous
décrivez en 10 ans en moyenne chacun
d'entre nous nous achetons 30 % de
vêtements de plus qui a 10 ans et
pourtant les enseignes physiques ferment
c'est bien la preuve que baisser la
consommation ou faire en sorte qu'on
aachète pas autant de vêtement ça ne
conduit pas à des fermetures la question
c'est quel type de vêtement à quel
endroit et en particulier la question de
la qualité la maladresse dans ce spot
c'était pas d'inciter à se poser la
question de savoir si on en a besoin
c'était de cibler un commerce physique
j'ai reçu la CPME le medf et 20
fédérations professionnelles au
ministère qui se sont déclaré satisfaite
non seulement de l'entretien mais de la
manière dont on allait dans les semaines
qui viennent imaginez sans doute une
campagne qui permette de porter un
message sur le soutien à au made in
France au fabriqués à proximité au
fabriqués en qualité au réparable pour
qu'on soit en capacité de porter un
double message qu'on doit à la fois
soutenir nos commerces et c'est ce que
j'ai fait dans ma vie élu local et que
je continue de m' forcer de faire et
dans le même temps de faire attention
aussi aux ressources de la planète parce
qu'on aurait tous à perdre de ne se
préoccuper qu'une seule de ces deux
cibles madame Gruny
oui merci alors sur les dévendeurs les
dégâts sont faits il y a pas de pas de
souci continuez comme ça et ce sera très
bien moi ma question c'était quand même
le soutien au au commerce de de
proximité particulièrement ils auraient
besoin d'un manager de ville et il faut
aider les les les communes justement à
offrir ça aux commerçants parce que ils
ont du mal à se battre contre le
e-commerce et puis aussi peut-être
baisser la TVA réfléchir à à à les aider
aussi de ce côté-là pour éviter les
concurrences déloyales en tout cas
vraiment he je vous invite monsieur le
ministre à venir faire vos courses
dimanche parce que eux ils travaillent
donc vous viendrez avec moi nous allons
faire nos courses à Tin et vous verrez
les messages des des commerçants et et
je vous assure que moi j'ai toutes les
semaines et que ils en ont assez assez
des taxes et qu'il faut les aider alors
les promesses bien entendu sont allé
dans votre bureau mais nous ce qu'on
veut ce sont des actes et c'est ce qu'on
compte suivre
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Franck Menonville pour le groupe de
l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires elle porte sur le
transfert de la compétence haut et
assaainissement des communes aux
intercommunalités ce transfert
obligatoire initialement prévu par la
loi nôtre au 1er janvier 2020 a été
reporté au 1er janvier 2026 par la loi
du 3 août 2018 et pour cause ce
transfert suscite beaucoup d'inquiétude
chez les élus locaux notamment dans sa
mise en œuvre depuis le Sénat n'a eu de
de se mobiliser pour le rappeler
dernière initiative en date de notre
assemblée la proposition loi portée par
notre collègue Jean iverrou qui
consacrait une approche différenciée de
la gestion de cette
compétence adopté à une large majorité
le 16 mars dernier le texte n'a pour
l'heure pas prospéré mais le 30 mars
dernier le président de la République en
déplacement dans les Hautes Alpes a
explicitement ouvert la voie à une
évolution notable dans ces conditions
monsieur le ministre alors que la date
de transfert au 1er janvier 2026
approche à grand pas où en sommes-nous
peut-on envisager que cette compétence
ne soit pas systématiquement transféré
aux intercommunaités peut envisager un
traitement différencié adapté aux
réalités territoriale sans revenir sur
une gestion purement communale
entendez-vous faire évoluer le cadre du
transfert et permettre aux communes de
s'organiser elle-même en en
bass'inversant autour des aires
d'alimentation par le biais de
structuresnd
notamment pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de la cohésion des
[Applaudissements]
territoires monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur maisénonville à la
fin de ces questions au Gouvernement
j'aurais donc une invitation à aller
faire le marché de Saint-Quentin à
retourner au côté des élus locaux dans
lesf je suis un peu déçu que vous ne
m'ayez pas proposé d'aller à steinville
pour qu'on puisse échanger ensemble sur
votre territoire vous avez raison la PPL
roue qui a été voté dans cette assemblée
n'a pour le moment pas trouvé de relais
auprès de l'Assemblée nationale à vrai
dire le texte a bien été repris par un
groupe il a été inscrit dans une niche
parlementaire mais dans cette niche
parlementaire il y avait tellement de
textes que la priorité a donneré un
autre et un en particulier visant à
abroger la réforme des retraites qui a
fini par tellement occuper l'Assemblée
nationale ce jour-là que le texte n'a
pas pu être évoqué et pourtant cette PPL
contient deux dimensions importantes une
que vous n'avez pas évoqué mais que je
rappelle parce que je pense qu'elle est
partagée sur tous les bancs ici et très
largement à l'extérieur qui est le fait
de permettre à nouveau au département de
pouvoir financer et sécuriser les
travaux qui concern les communes cet
engagement la première ministre a eu
l'occasion de le rappeler en marge du
congrès de laadf au président saovadet
pour dire à quel point nous soutenions
ce point qui est le point 35 de du plan
haut présenté à Savine leelac le 30 mars
dernier la deuxième dimension dont vous
parlez je vois le président Arnaud qui
s'en souvient parfaitement c'est que ce
jour-là à Savine de lac le président de
la République a dit qu'il fallait sans
doute ne pas imaginer qu'un jardin à la
française était le meilleur moyen de
gérer la compétence eau partout dans
notre pays et que comp tenu de la taille
moyenne d'un certain nombre
d'intercommunalité il fallait imaginer
un dispositif qui tienne compte de deux
impératifs j'insiste et Dominique fort à
laquelle je rends hommage parce queelle
a eu à la fois l'occasion de s'investir
sur le Tex jusqu'à maintenant et de elle
va elle a vocation à continuer à le
faire a pu le préciser
1 nous ne pouvons
pas retourner vers un système ou
conserver un système de commune
isolé je le dis parce que dans ce
contexte quand on superpose la réalité
des communes en rupture d'eau et les
taux de fuite on s'aperçoit que c'est
une fausse bonne idée de obliger à
l'intercommunalité en n'acceptant pas
qu'on puisse avoir entre les deux un
système ou de syndicat ou de coopération
c'est une souplesse que nous devons
trouver et à laquelle en 2024 nous
trouverons le débouché le véhicule
législatif pour assurer la la suite de
la PPL
rou Monsieur
mononville Merci monsieur le ministre
pour votre réponse il existe vous l'avez
dit donc du temps gouvernemental pour le
mettre à l'ordre du jour de de
l'Assemblée nationale moi je voudrais
seulement peut-être vous dire que
permettez-moi donc d'évoquer que
malheureusement dans notre pays il y a
suffisamment de réformes à conduire de
dysfonctionnement dans nos politiques
publiques il faut pas désorganiser ce
qui est organisé sur les territoire donc
il faut de la souplesse et permettre je
crois que c'est important une délégation
directe des communes aux structures de
leur choix sans systématiquement des sub
délégations par les
EPCI
[Applaudissements]
merci nous en avons terminé avec les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
les prochaines auront lieu le mercredi
20 décembre je vais suspendre la séance
merci Madame la première ministre merci
mesdames et messieurs les ministres elle
sera reprise à 16h35 pour l'examen de la
proposition de loi visant à favoriser le
réemploi des véhicules au service des
mobilités durables et solidairirees sur
les territoires la séance est
suspendue voilà pour cette séance de
question au gouvernement que vous avez
pu suivre en direct et en intégralité
sur Public Sénat une séance qui
s'inscrit dans un contexte bien
particulier alors que le rejet par
l'Assemblée lundi de du projet de loi
immigration ce texte phare du
gouvernement plonge l'exécutif dans la
crise et cette situation a d'ailleurs
fait l'objet de plusieurs questions dans
l'hémicycle notamment au début de la
séance
Quentin question au total et la séance
qui a été marquée effectivement par ces
échanges parfois ouleux entre les
groupes surtout de gauche et le
gouvernement la gauche à l'image de
Patrick canner qui a dit que et bien au
travers de cet échec c'est le président
de la République qui a échoué et le
président du groupe PS au Sénat de
réclamer le retrait du projet de loi
immigration la première ministre a
dénoncé une alliance baroque je cite
lundi à l'Assemblée nationale avec le
vote de la gauche et du rassemblement
national ensemble dans cette motion de
rejet préalable adoptée lundi écoutez la
chef du gouvernement tout à l'heure je
me souviens d'un temps où le parti
socialiste portait des combats et des
valeurs
d'un temps où il défendait avec force le
Parlement le Parti socialiste était un
parti de gouvernement à l'Assemblée de
plus en plus il s'enferme dans
l'obstruction la première ministre qui a
répondu trois fois à des groupes de
gauche et qui a ménagé la droite qui a
ménagé l'ELR en ommettant de rappeler
que ces députés des républicains ont
également voté la motion lundi mais la
première ministre espère parvenir à un
accord lundi en commission mixte
paritaire notamment entre la droite et
les marcheurs écoutez justement la
réaction de Patrick canner dans à cette
situation politique tout à l'heure
excusez-moi de vous rappeler que le 14
novembre ici les sénateurs de votre
groupe majoritaire à quelques exceptions
ont voter le texte de la droite
sénatoriale avec toutes les suppressions
que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure
alors je n'ai pas de leçons à recevoir
au nom de mon groupe ne laissez pas vos
députés Renaissance se dissoudre parmi
les députés LR qui se dissouent qui se
dissolvent eux-mêmes dans les groupes de
la République de la du rassemblement
national voilà la réalité voilà la
réalité qui est posée madame la
premierre ministre retirez votre texte
voilà au total Tam quatre questions sur
cette crise et un un niveau d'énervement
rarement atteint entre l'exécutif et la
gauche de l'hémicycle Tam merci merci
beaucoup Quentin pour toutes ces
explications et place à présent aux
réactions politiques d'abord et bien
salle des
conférences car Alexandre vous êtes avec
Christophe Béchu le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires on va parler de
l'actualité du projet de loi immigration
mais aussi de l'actualité internationale
et cet accord qualifié par certains
d'historiques de la COP 28 ce matin
effectivement bonjour Christophe Béchu
bonjour on va parler dans un instant de
cet accord qualifié d'historique de la
COP 28 à Dubaï mais d'abord une question
sur le projet de loi immigration ça a
été un sujet dans les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement cet
après-midi Christophe Béchu vous votre
parcours politique vous venez de des
républicains maintenant vous faites
partie de la majorité présidentielle
d'horizon au côté d'eddouard Philippe
qu'est-ce que vous inspire ces
républicains qui ont mêlé leur voix à
celle de la France insoumise du
rassemblée nationale pour rejeter un
débat sur ce texte immigration je je
regrette je trouve que les républicains
ont été autrement plus dignes ici au
Sénat en allant au bout d'un débat et et
et cette alliance c'est quand même
l'alliance de ceux qui expliquent qu'il
faut plus de frontières comme Madame
Rousseau de ceux qui faut plus
d'immigration comme Madame Le Pen et que
les républicains renoncent en quelque
sorte à peser sur le cours des débats
qui refusent même qu'il y ait un débat
je pense qu'en fait ce que ça reflète
c'est qu'ils étaient tellement divisés
qu'ils n'avaient pas envie d'exposer
leur division article par article sur
les différents sujets mais c'est pas la
hauteur de l'enjeu notre pays ne peut
pas ne pas disposer d'un texte pour être
plus ferme sur les questions migratoires
quand on voit aujourd'hui la réalité euh
d'abord ce qui se passe dans les pays
européens qui nous entourent où il y a
constat qui se diffuse et puis ensuite
les besoins que nous avons de pouvoir
expulser ceux qui sont les les plus
dangereux alors il y a un texte
immigration qui a été voté ici au Sénat
il sera la base de la négociation lundi
entre se députés se sénateurs dans la
commission mixte paritaire c'est un un
bon texte ce texte de la droite
sénatoriale qui est assez ferme quand
même sur les questions migratoires moi
je vous rappelle que j'appartiens au
mouvement politique d'Édouard Philippe
horizon et que le groupe Horizon a dit
au moment du vote ici que le texte du
Sénat convenait au groupe horizon à
l'exception de l'aide médicale d'État où
on pense que il faut pas tout mélanger
et que faire en sorte de préserver une
dimension qui permette de soigner ceux
qui sont malad sur notre sol c'est pas
seulement les protéger eux c'est aussi
protéger toute la population et ce sont
de de mauvaises économies il y a
peut-être quelques abus qu'il faut
évidemment sanctionner mais pas au point
de remettre en cause un dispositif dont
nous avons besoin d'un point de vue
sanitaire donc pour vous il doit y avoir
un accord si on enlève cette restriction
de l'aide médicale d'État voté par les
sénateurs avec comme base le texte du
Sénat je pense que le texte du Sénat une
base sur laquelle on peut travailler il
y a d'autres pointes dans la diversité
de la majorité qui certainement sont des
irritants au-delà de la question de la
me mais il y a un socle autour duquel on
doit être capable de construire un
compromis alors Christophe Béchu votre
réaction justement à cet accord de la
COP 28 à Dubaï qui prévoit une
transition hors des énergies fossiles
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone en
2050 est-ce que c'est vraiment un accord
historique comme certains le qualifient
il a deux dimensions historiques jusqu'à
maintenant tout le monde disait il y a
un dérèglement climatique c'est une
réalité mais on disait pas à quoi il
était dû là pour la première fois on dit
bah il y a quand même un lien avec les
énergies fossiles et on le fait où on le
fait dans un pays qui vend massivement
du pétrole donc ces deux dimensions là
elles sont cruciales et elles sont
historiques maintenant il faut mesurer
le fait que un accord ça veut pas dire
que tout est réglé mais on parle de 195
pays ici il s'agit de se mettre d'accord
à 6 ou 7 groupes vous imaginez ce que
c'est 195 pays avec des pays aussi
divers que des petites d'îes directement
menacé par la montée des eau et des pays
qui bénéficient d'une rente p ère qui
fait leur richesse depuis des
générations et donc qu'on ait réussi à à
cranter ce type d'accord c'est une bonne
nouvelle que dans cet accord on disent
il faut tripler les énergies
renouvelables on va accélérer sur le
nucléaire on va lutter contre la
déforestation ce sont des points
importants il reste plein de choses à
faire assurer les financement faire en
sorte de respecter les engagements mais
toute la petite musique qui com s que
ces engagements soi respectés que ça se
traduit en acte juste avant de vous
répondre tous ceux qui disent les cops
ça sert à rien on se réunit il y a plein
de gens plus ils y vont en avion ils
discutent à la fin il se passe rien je
veux juste rappeler une chose tout n'est
pas parfait avec les COP mais s'il y
avait pas de Cop qui croit vraiment que
chaque pays irait plus vite pour se
décarboné avant Paris avant l'accord de
Paris la trajectoire de réchauffement
c'était 4 degrés on est à 3 c'est encore
beaucoup trop mais les efforts ont déjà
permis d'avancer comment on fait
maintenant on continue à utiliser la
diplomatie environnementale il y a des
budgets qui sont prévus en particulier
pour que des pays plutôt que de miser
sur des centrale à charbon puisse
investir ou dans du petit nucléaire ou
dans du renouvelable de manière à ce que
on se prépare un monde dans lequel on
n'ura pas collectivement à payer une
autre facture qui est pas la facture de
la transition qui serait la facture de
l'inaction et celle-là elle serait
d'autant plus douloureuse que
entre-temps on aurait causé des dégâts
irrémédiables à la faune à la flore et à
l'humanité merci beaucoup mon ministre
pour votre
réaction merci merci beaucoup Alexandre
pour cette première réaction et puis je
le disais tout à l'heure une grande
partie de cette séance de question
gouvernement a aussi bien sûr porté sur
le projet de loi immigration sur ce
texte Alexandre vous êtes avec le
président du groupe Union centriste
Hervé Marseille bonjour Hervé Marseille
bonjour vous avez donc été reçu ce midi
par la première ministre Élisabeth bne
pour évoquer le projet de loi
immigration et la commission mixte
paritaire de ce lundi quel message vous
a-elle passé est-ce qu'elle a défini les
lignes rouges dans la négociation entre
la majorité présidentielle et la droite
et le centre du
Sénat d'abord premièrement le Sénat a
toujours été attentif à ce qu'il y ait
un texte ça a été le cas pour les rraite
ça a été le cas pour l'immigration donc
nous sommes désireux qu'il y ait un
texte au Sénat et nous groupe PUC nous
souhaitons aboutir donc la première
ministre a évoqué les points qui
pouvaient
faire difficultés lesquels oh le code de
la nationalité la donc le durcissement
de l'accès à la nationalité voilà et
restri de médical d'État donc on peut
aboutir à un accord
mais les conditions ne sont pas encore
réunies pour qu'il y ait un accord parce
que ce ce sont des sujets qui sont
difficiles et il y a une double
condition c'est de trouver un accord
pour la commission mix paritaire mais
également un accord susceptible d'être
validé par le Sénat et par l'Assemblée
nationale donc il faut satisfaire les
deux assemblées c'est un exercice
difficile donc est-ce qu'il y a un
accord global sur l'ensemble du texte ça
veut dire abandonner de part et d'autrre
un certain nombre de choses ou alors un
accord partiel sur une partie du texte
et justement donc ces lignes rouges fixé
par Elisabeth borne la restriction de
l'aide médicale d'État le durcissement
de l'accès à la nationalité est-ce que
vous demandez à vos collègues sénateurs
les républicains d'être souple et de
faire ces concessions d'abandonner ces
mesures non j'en ai pas le pouvoir
simplement on va dialoguer envoyer un
message on va dialoguer avec nos
collègues du groupe républicain comme on
le fait d'habitude dans dans le cadre de
la majorité sénatoriale euh chacun va
évaluer j'allais dire jusqu'où il est
prêt à aller pour trouver un accord et
puis on R verra certainement la la
premier la première ministre mais on a
l'impression que en tout cas vos
collègues de la majorité les
républicains sont très durs ils veulent
absolument le texte du Sénat est-ce que
du côté des centristes où on souhaite
peut-être davantage un accord de cette
négociation et bien on appelle à faire
des concessions du côté du Sénat moi je
suis ravi d'abord de de constater que on
trouve beaucoup de vertu désormais au
texte du Sénat euh c'était pas le cas au
moment où il a été voté il est jamais
trop tard pour pour bien faire euh c'est
le texte du Sénat aujourd'hui qui
prévaut il faut pouvoir faire des
concessions je pense qu'on on peut pas
faire non plus n'importe quoi parce que
c'est le fruit d'un compromis ici et
donc je ne sais pas jusqu'où on peut
aller pour
satisfaire la majorité un accord et
l'Assemblée nationale je pense que il y
a un certain nombre de compromis
possibles mais pas sur des choses
essentielles maintenant nous préférons
un texte global qu' un texte partiel
c'est évident euh
je pense qu'on peut trouver euh est-ce
qu'il faut s'accrocher à à l'aide
médicale d'État à cette restriction
l'aide médicale d'État peut faire
l'objet la première ministre l'avait
déjà annoncé euh un accord à partir d'un
texte qui serait discuté au mois de
janvier donc euh on dit que c'est un
cavalier législatif on peut le sortir
euh du texte immigration et en faire un
un
texte qui soit un texte différent mais
au tout début de l'année reste euh les
problèmes de code de la nationalité euh
qui sont importants euh les textes
également concernant les allocations euh
on le rappelle la droite sénatoriale
souhaite que les certaines prestations
sociales soient conditionnées à 50
résidences régulières aujourd'hui c'est
6 mois ça c'est c'est une ligne rouge il
un point de blocage pour l'instant pour
l'instant ça fait l'objet de de
discussion donc nous allons en parler
entre nous moi j'espère qu'on trouve des
solutions parce que au fond au bout de
tout cela ce qui importe c'est de
trouver des réponses c'est ce
qu'attendent nos concitoyens